While some common gestures, such as the high
five, have pretty well known and surprisingly
modern origins, it turns out one of the most
popular of all has been around for well over
two thousand years, including having various
similar connotations as it has today.
Unsurprisingly once you stop and think about
versions of the expression’s meaning, extending
the middle finger simply represents the phallus,
with it perhaps natural enough that our forebears
chose their longest finger to symbolically
represent man’s favorite digit.
(Although, there are some cultures that instead
chose the thumb, seemingly preferring to have
their girth, rather than length, represented
here…)
It’s also been speculated that perhaps people
noticed that the curled fingers (or balled
fist in the case of the thumb) made for a
good representation of the testicles.
Either way, given the symbolism here, it’s
no surprise that the expression has more or
less always seemed to have meant something
akin to “F&*k You” in some form or other,
sometimes literally.
For example, in Ancient Greece, beyond being
a general insult, in some cases there seems
to be a specific implication from the insult
that the person the gesture was directed at
liked to take it up the bum.
In the case of men, despite male on male lovin’
being widely accepted in the culture at the
time, there were still potentially negative
connotations with regards to one’s manliness
when functioning as the bottom in such a rendezvous,
particularly the bottom for someone with lower
social standing.
Moving on to an early specific example we
have Aristphanes’ 423 BC The Clouds.
In it, a character known as Strepsiades, tired
of Socrates’ pontificating, decides to flip
off the famed philosopher.
SOCRATES: Well, to begin with,
they’ll make you elegant in company—
and you’ll recognize the different rhythms,
the enoplian and the dactylic,
which is like a digit.
STREPSIADES: Like a digit!
By god, that’s something I do know!
SOCRATES: Then tell me.
STREPSIADES: When I was a lad a digit meant
this!
[Strepsiades sticks his middle finger straight
up under Socrates’ nose]
For whatever it’s worth, in the third century
AD Lives of the Eminent Philosophers, we also
have this reference of a supposed incidence
that occurred in the 4th century BC, concerning
famed orator Demosthenes and philosopher Diogenes.
[Diogenes] once found Demosthenes the orator
lunching at an inn, and, when he retired within,
Diogenes said, “All the more you will be
inside the tavern.”
When some strangers expressed a wish to see
Demosthenes, [Diogenes] stretched out his
middle finger and said, “There goes the
demagogue of Athens.”
(No doubt water was needed to put out the
fire created by that wicked burn.)
Moving on to the first century AD, Caligula
seems to have enjoyed making powerful people
kiss his ring while he extended his middle
finger at them.
On a no doubt completely unrelated note, the
chief organizer of his assassination, and
first to stab him, was one Cassius Chaerea
who Caligula liked to do this very thing with,
as noted by Suetonius:
Gaius used to taunt him, a man already well
on in years, with voluptuousness and effeminacy
by every form of insult.
When he asked for the watchword Gaius would
give him “Priapus” or “Venus,” and
when Chaerea had occasion to thank him for
anything, he would hold out his hand to kiss,
forming and moving it in an obscene fashion.
Speaking of the implications of this insulting
gesture, it seems to have fallen out of favor
during the Middle Ages with the rise of Christianity,
or at least records of it diminish.
This may mean people actually stopped popularly
flipping the bird or may just mean its uncouth
nature saw it something not generally written
about.
That said, we do know thanks to the Etymologiae
of Isidore of Seville that at least as late
as the 6th century people were still extending
the finger as an insult, in this reference
particularly directed at someone who had done
something considered “shameful”.
Moving on to more modern times, the gesture
was popularly resurrected in documented history
starting around the early 19th century, with
early photographic evidence later popping
up in the latter half of the 1800s.
Most famously, we have a photograph of the
gesture flashed by present day Twitter sensation
and former 19th century baseball iron man
Charley “Old Hoss” Radbourn.
Radbourn was a pitcher for the Boston Beaneaters
in 1886 when the team, along with the New
York Giants, posed for a group photo.
In the photo, Old Hoss can be seen giving
the bird to the cameraman.
(We’ll have more on Charley “Hoss” and
his possible connection to a different expression
in a bit.)
At this point you might be wondering why we
call extending the middle finger today- “flipping
the bird” or “giving the bird”.
The connection is speculated to derive from
the centuries old practice of more or less
making bird sounds, particularly owl and geese
calls, as an equivalent to booing when an
audience is dissatisfied by something.
This, in turn, gave rise to the popular 19th
century expression to “goose” someone
and then a little later led to the expression
“give the big bird”, as noted in William
Earnest Henley’s late 19th century work,
Slang and Its Analogues Past and Present:
Big Bird: To get or give the big bird- To
be hissed on the stage….
When an actor or actress gets the big bird,
it may be from two causes; either it is a
compliment for successful portrayal of villainy,
in which case the Gods simply express their
abhorrence of the character and not of the
actor; or, the hissing may be directed against
the actor, personally for some reason or other.
The Big Bird is the goose.
By the mid-20th century, this seems to have
extended to “giving the bird” not just
referring to insulting sounds, but to describe
extending the middle finger as well.
One of the earliest examples of this can be
found in the 1942 animated film A Tale of
Two Kitties.
In it, the pair of cats attempt to capture
Tweety bird.
At a certain point, one of the cats implores
the other “Give me the bird!”
The other cat then turns to the viewers and
exclaims “If the Hays Office would only
let me, I’d give him the bird alright.”
Going
back
to
Charley “Hoss” Roadbourn, he is widely
speculated to be the inspiration for the expression
“Charley Horse”, indicating a random muscle
cramp in the leg.
The expression popped up in baseball shortly
after his historic 1884 season in which he
posted a 1.38 ERA with 441 strikeouts in 678
and 2/3 innings, winning 59 games by modern
rules (or 60 by the scorers of the day) despite
the fact that his team only played 112 games
that year.
If you’re wondering how he managed to pitch
in so many games, this was as a result of
a fight between he and the team’s other
best pitcher, Charlie Sweeney, that saw Sweeney
leave and Old Hoss offer to start every game
for the remainder of the season.
He nearly did this, starting 40 of the remaining
43 games that year and winning 36 of them.
However, at a certain point he reportedly
became so sore he couldn’t even raise his
arm above his head without significant warmup
that required starting by soft tossing from
just a few feet and slowly working back as
his arm loosened up.
It is speculated that his prolific pitching
around this time, and presumably frequent
cramps from over use of his muscles, may have
inspired the expression.
For whatever it’s worth, a 1907 issue of
the Washington Post indicates that Old Hoss
actually once had a severe leg cramp in a
game, which directly gave rise to the expression.
Whatever the case, one of the earliest known
instances of the expression “Charley Horse”
occurred in an 1887 edition of The Fort Wayne
Gazette where it notes, “Whatever ails a
player this year they call it a ‘Charley
horse’…”
American seamen captured by the North Koreans
in the famous “Pueblo crisis” once used
the North Korean’s ignorance of the meaning
of extending the middle finger to good use
in propaganda photos taken by their captors.
When asked, the captured men simply stated
that it was a good luck gesture, so were allowed
to continue using it in the photographs…
at first.
When the North Koreans discovered what it
actually meant, the seamen were beaten.
As we alluded to in the body of this piece,
there are several places on Earth where a
thumbs up has a similar meaning to extending
the middle finger.
Why we bring this up specifically is that
when American troops first started being stationed
in Iraq, some reported being greeted by civilians
offering a thumbs up, with the soldiers (and
many in the media) interpreting it as most
Westerners would- all the while not realizing
the people were more or less flipping them
off.